welcome to this video on playing Apollo
Creed Pollock read from Denmark and
played him before and no absolutely no
game to see how the name in there no
well it's played a couple of five minute
games already without them ever being
paired against me okay so what about
this this a for business I could play
what about Bishop d7 this is interesting
maybe I can go here I really put it on
this seven maybe it's not it's not so
bad okay I'd like to get the seaport
involved it's hard to play without that
yeah these some slower slow build ups
with the d3 have gained in popularity
and recent yes on all levels yeah well
the top players always the trendsetters
father for the crowd so while on top
level of people just want to avoid the
marshal attack on a lower level at
simply copying the the good guys and I
it's not it's not bad at leads to a
playable position and without so I'm so
much theoretical knowledge needed um
okay so what is he doing is sweeping to
d5 interesting
you know what can you do and probably
you will just put it on d5 it's not it's
not the end of the world well if maybe
there are some technical issues now that
I think of it with a B and so on and
could be going to detune interesting
yeah there are some some technical
issues here I move the Queen there's a
capture 95
and this also sometimes takes takes
before
yeah I wonder if I should put something
now let's do that cavity 5 so that I can
just take a piece that appears down I
mean the piece of the night of this live
not much not not any other piece coming
to d5 at least not in the near future
interesting now I not how many cans we
can open up the center it's not them
nothing bad about it um I can try though
if i take here and play Knight b3 i will
grab the bishops is that technical
drawback to that I don't see it I don't
see it at the moment five well ok it's
too complicated to really calculate to
the end but this looks uh looks fine
actually I'm taking here I loses loses a
piece I better not
ok my teens the curry now he might meet
the Queen but then I can take on d floor
this is not good ok but this unless I'm
mmm falling victim to some direct tactic
this should be quite good for me yeah
efore was hanging I can play Knight g4
but I mean if or still is hanging 94
Bishop g7 night h6 takes takes rupee for
this probably ok ok taking here ok check
now some here at the end of all this the
back rank is important of course you can
try to just cover the black ranked like
rookie for Queenie for and then h3 or
something ok night g5
95 and I need to do I have some move to
cover c5 and cover the back rank and
still keep pressure on the back rank
time warning and I don't see one at the
moment and interesting I can go here
actually 43 seconds here with that time
the draw is probably ok but i think you
will avoid it
now it's simply much easier for white to
play I'm not sure about the quality of
the position objectively but it's it's
just easier for wide to play
it's possible that objectively black is
is in good shape I've got two against
one enter with Queens offer I'm winning
the endgame easily but yeah the Queen's
are on the board and I've got 27 seconds
no sacks is probably not ending too well
just practical purposes this is
difficult
Joe cannot really calculate any more hip
check okay
check check jump back and I could also
resigned this I even went on time anyway
besides the fact that it's that it's
lost of course yeah I came at the NT
you've managed to get to this end game
which was was one of the bad end games
injective Lee I think black is perfectly
all right Hannah they are Queen D file
for example i just have the better minor
piece here if I'm not mated and so I
don't I don't think I am um yeah very
very tricky you know here Queen a1 check
for instance just wins the game check
and that take it down I can take it mmm
yeah this I should have done it's also
much easier than to play yeah I spent
far too much time before and on some
stuff and that I'm not pick what is it
way off so I came so we got here yeah I
came this was too passive then I mean
this is perfectly okay for black but
it's just tricky to play against Queen
at night combination with little time it
can easily drop a pond somewhere
actually if you defended it into it
quite well I only need to play a queen d
5 24 s is just just losing there's also
the the king and porn endgame
just check and then F for ya goes to f3
g-form that's just to win yeah okay it's
hard to have a play with 20 seconds I
should just go here and I'm okay i can
get a check but i just go go to g6
that's not much not much happening yeah
a bad time management in this game
alright thanks for watching